Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This piece of work is not meant to be a highly
useful application, only a tongue in cheek
jab at the rising trend of trying to solve
simple problems using deep learning without
carefully examining the problem at hand.
As always, we note that all intuitive explanations
are wrong, but some are helpful, and the most
precise way to express these thoughts can
be done by using mathematics.
However, we shall leave that to the textbooks
and will try to understand these concepts
by floating about on the wings of intuition.
In mathematics, a matrix is a rectangular
array in which we can store numbers and symbols.
Matrices can be interpreted in many ways,
for instance, we can think of them as transformations.
Multiplying a matrix with a vector means applying
this transform to the vector, such as scaling,
rotation or shearing.
The rank of a matrix can be intuitively explained
in many ways.
My favorite intuition is that the rank encodes
the information content of the matrix.
For instance, in an earlier work on Separable
Subsurface Scattering, we recognized that
many of these matrices that encode light scattering
inside translucent materials, are of relatively
low rank.
This means that the information within is
highly structured and it is not random noise.
And from this low rank property follows that
we can compress and represent this phenomenon
using simpler data structures, leading to
an extremely efficient algorithm to simulate
light scattering within our skin.
However, the main point is that finding out
the rank of a large matrix is an expensive
operation.
It is also important to note that we can also
visualize these matrices by mapping the numbers
within to different colors.
As a fun sidenote, the paper finds, that the
uglier the colorscheme is, the better suited
it is for learning.
This way, after computing the ranks of many
matrices, we can create a lot of input images
and output ranks for the neural network to
learn on.
After that, the goal is that we feed in an
unknown matrix in the form of an image, and
the network would have to guess what the rank
is.
It is almost like having an expert scientist
unleash his intuition on such a matrix, much
like a fun guessing game for intoxicated mathematicians.
And the ultimate question, as always is, how
does this knowledge learned by the neural
network generalize?
The results are decent, but not spectacular,
but they also offer some insights as to which
matrices have surprising ranks.
We can also try computing the products of
matrices, which intuitively translates to
guessing the result after we have done one
transformation after the other.
Like the output of scaling after a rotation
operation.
They also tried to compute the inverse of
matrices, for which the intuition can be undoing
the transformation.
If it is a rotation to a given direction,
the inverse would be rotating back the exact
same amount, or if we scaled something up,
then scaling it back down would be its inverse.
Of course, these are not the only operations
that we can do with matrices, we only used
these for the sake of demonstration.
The lead author states on his website that
this paper shows that "linear algebra can
be replaced with machine learning".
Talk about being funny and tongue in cheek.
Also, I have linked the website of David in
the description box, he has a lot of great
works and I am surely not doing him justice
by of all those great works, covering this
one.
Rufus von Woofles, graduate of the prestigious
Muddy Paws University was the third author
of the paper, overlooking the entirety of
the work and making sure that the quality
of the results is impeccable.
As future work, I would propose replacing
the basic mathematical operators such as addition
and multiplication by machine learning.
Except that it is already done and is hilariously
fun, and it even supports division by zero.
Talk about the almighty powers of deep learning.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!